foreign
[Music]
welcome welcome everyone
welcome all you folks online we are so
glad to see you all here today
thank you for coming
so we have a couple of announcements for
y'all my name is Janine Horton
uh today is one of my favorite days
it is first Sunday Community Mill meal
at hat Creek Burger Company in Sachse
got it right yeah yeah in Sachse so uh
it'll be right after the service and
everyone is welcome
okay and put on your calendars October
the 22nd because that is going to be our
youth Sunday service
and it'll be a special service planned
and led by our amazing teens table teens
all right so if everyone will just take
a deep breath with me
ah
and just relax and leave all of those
cares and troubles and everything that
you've had
during the week
and bring yourself
here
for us to begin to worship
we're really glad to have you guys with
us if you'll stand we're going to start
with some music and I pray that as we
worship together tonight kind of our our
common theme as we went through the set
and talked afterwards and prayed is just
that hope that you feel less alone
I know a lot of us are either carrying
heavy things or connected to people who
are carrying heavy things and as a
community one of the biggest gifts in my
life is not having to walk through it
alone so um I hope that as we worship
that these lyrics and the music that
it's able to minister to the places in
your heart wherever where you have felt
maybe isolated
um or where you have felt discouraged
that you will feel some Hope Rising up
in those places and know that you're
seeing that your story matters that we
love you guys and that we're here
together
um through the thick and thin so Josh is
going to get us started tonight with
stand in your love and because I see a
couple faces that I haven't met before
or maybe that are new I just wanted to
introduce the people that are up here
because we are a family this is not like
the performance band so we want to know
you guys and we want you all to know us
this is Josh and Joe Brock and yes
they're fabulous wonderful people
um this is my twin Maggie so if you feel
like you're seeing double we're twins
this is Maggie Tilford who is also
married to Brett our pastor
um just connecting dots and then this is
Jesse that's Justice's dad
Jesse Watts he also sometimes is on
Guitar and so you'll see him kind of
move around he's multi-talented
so anyways we're glad that y'all are
with us and we're gonna get started
Mindy
I'm Mindy
all right
[Music]
beside steel the joy I hope
shaken
[Music]
I won't be shaking
my fear doesn't stand a chance
[Music]
thank you
sing no longer has the place to hide
to the last
not afraid to leave my past behind
that won't be shaken but I won't be
shaking
my fear doesn't stand a chance when I
stand in your blood my fear doesn't
stand a chance when I stand in your love
my fear doesn't stand a chance when I
stand In Your Love
this power that can break off every
chain
[Music]
this resurrection power that can't say
is power in your name is power in your
name
power that can break off every chain
power that can empty out
the outs Resurrection
[Music]
doesn't stand a chance when I stand in
your love my fear it doesn't stand a
chance when I stepped in your love my
fear doesn't stand a chance when I stand
in your love my fear he doesn't stand a
chance when I stand in your love my fear
doesn't stand a chance when I stand in
your life my fear doesn't stand a chance
when I stand In Your Love
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you guys you're dismissed if
you're a kid and
um this classroom over here to my right
is for a second through sixth and over
here to my left is four years through
first grade and then our young Toddlers
and babies are back there in the nursery
and as always I just want to thank all
you kids ministry workers who are loving
on our kids and taking care of them each
Sunday
such a gift they are so much
we're going to move into the prayers of
the people now so if you guys would
follow along on the screens with me
this is something that throughout
Christian history has been known as
prayers of the people and we're going to
begin by reading this prayer aloud
together and then we'll leave space for
you to speak out a name or a situation
that you want to hold up in prayer
before God
um so just say that name or whatever
you're carrying on your hearts you can
say it out loud if you're online with us
you can leave it in the comments we try
to watch those when we can and share
them with the room if we have the
opportunity
and then at the end of that moment we
will close with a prayer together again
so would you guys join us as we pray
aloud
Jesus for this city of Sachse Texas and
for every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you
for The Good Earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it we pray to you
for the old and the sick for the Widow
and orphan for the injured and suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them
pray to you
for the vulnerable the marginalized and
those unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you
for those experiencing loss loneliness
and disconnection and for those
struggling with mental and emotional
health we pray to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us and so we lift these names
and situations up to you
[Music]
foreign
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence
amen
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
together
at the feet of Jesus
[Music]
carried on but your heart was tired fear
the worst and felt the fire lay it all
down
it all down
filled with all those anxious thoughts
all your doubts became your God lay it
all down
[Music]
lay it all down at the feet of Jesus
at the feet
of Jesus
[Music]
lay it all down
play it all down lay it all down
at the feet of Jesus
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
laid it all down
laid all down
[Music]
play it all down lay it all down
lay it all down
[Music]
at the feet of Jesus
is
Jesus
[Music]
there's a Grace when the Heart Is Under
Fire
another way when the walls are closing
in
then I look at the space between where I
used to be and this Reckoning
I know I will never be alone
there was another in the fire
standing next to me there was another in
the waters
holding back the Seas should I ever need
reminding
how I've been set free there is across
that there's a burden where another died
for me
there is another in the fire
[Music]
and all my dead left for dead beneath
the waters
and I'm no longer a slave to my sin
anymore
should I fall in the space between
them be and this Reckoning
either way I won't bow to the things of
this world
[Music]
there'll be another in the fire
standing next to me there is another in
the waters
holding back the Seas and should I ever
need reminding or the power Set Me Free
there is a grave that holds nobody and
now the power lives in me there's
another in the fire
[Music]
there is another in the fire oh
oh there is another in the fire
oh there is another in the fire oh
and I can see the light in the darkness
as the darkness bows to him and I can
hear the roar in the heavens as a space
between prayers that I can feel the
ground shake beneath us as a Prison
Walls cave in nothing stands between us
nothing stands between us
thank you
[Music]
there is no other name but the name that
is Jesus
you words and still lives and will be
through it all
foreign
[Music]
standing next to me there'll be another
in the waters
[Music]
to me I'll count the joy come every
battle cause I know that's where you'll
be and I can see the light in the
darkness as the darkness bows to him I
can hear the Roar
[Music]
nothing stands between us nothing stands
between us
in the darkness as the darkness bows to
him I can hear the roar in the heavens
as a space between where's this I can
feel the ground shake beneath us as a
Prison Walls came in nothing stands
between us nothing stands between
us nothing stands between
[Music]
there'll be another in the fire
standing next to me
there'll be another in the world
[Music]
counter Joy come every battle
I know that's where you'll be
should I come every battle
I'll count the joy come every battle
cause I know that's where you'll be
God I'm so grateful
for the times
that you've Stood Beside us
[Music]
that you've seen us through the darkness
that you've held our hands
as we fall apart
[Music]
as the world around us sometimes is
falling apart
but God I can say in honesty that you
have been the anchor you have been the
goodness you have been the lifeline and
the hope
it's your face that I've seen in the
people who've stood around us and given
love and support and prayers and shown
up practically and paid for meals and
the little things God it's you it's your
love
[Music]
people for community
I'm so grateful for the way that you
weave us together our stories our
Brokenness
and you make something beautiful of our
mess
God would you be a Lifeline to those who
need it tonight even in this room in
this building God would you be the one
holding them together picking up the
pieces weaving Something Beautiful
I have seen you do it and I believe you
will continue to do it for us God
[Music]
thank you that that's the kind of God
you are
[Music]
those are the kind of people that we
want to be for others
believing for the very best
for each other
[Music]
we love you God
working in us help us to see you
and know when you're at work
follow you
with all our hearts
in Jesus name
amen
thank you guys for worshiping with us if
y'all would turn to the people around
you make them feel welcome get to know
them if you've never met them before
real quick and then Brett will get us
started on our message
foreign
well good evening grace and peace it is
so good to be with you all my name is
Brett and uh yeah it's a joy a joy to be
with you a joy to welcome you into this
space and as always that includes those
joining us online love you all Lots and
anyone here who is new or maybe this is
your first time or first time in a long
time uh whatever the case we're just
really really glad that you're here and
and I recognize it's often um
you know it can be a challenge and kind
of um what to say a lot of folks visit
here not always but often with kind of
high stakes like maybe there was a lot
of rejection in a previous Church
community uh previous
um kind of even friendships and
relationships sometimes
well often people will visit and like
this is kind of their last
stop at a church like sort of I'll give
it one more go God you know that kind of
thing before I think I'm like I still
love you I just I don't know if I can do
church anymore you know and so all the
to say I just I recognize the stakes are
um really high for many of you and so I
just want to name that a I um or we
recognize that and um and B I hope that
we can just love you well you know as
opposed to like trying to I don't know
like we can really oh this sermon it's
gonna be so good it'll just keep you I
don't know um but I just I hope we can
love you well and you can sense that in
and somehow oh wow so loud
um
uh that somehow that would it would um
communicate you know um God's love to
you so um yeah that's kind of my my
heart and
and the Lord blessed is like I love all
these kids we're so blessed aren't we I
mean I know it can get a little crazy
but hey we'll take it the more kids the
better they're a blessing
um in our midst I don't know maybe
there's someone I don't know but uh
um so we are kicking off a new series
tonight titled the Bible doesn't say
that
and the idea is basically there's all
these kind of phrases you know um kind
of out in the culture that sound there's
kind of spiritual they sound sort of
christiany you know and so we often I
think just assume like oh that's in the
Bible and uh often nope it's not and I
mean that's some certain ones like we'll
we'll look at some that I think aren't
like oh it's the worst thing you know um
so at best they're kind of I don't know
at times like it's a lot of bumper
sticker theology that's what I call it
you know just kind of like quick little
pithy things I kind of roll off the
tongue and you know at best they're just
sort of I don't know lack Nuance you
know maybe that's the nature of
something being so short and catchy you
know it kind of lacks Nuance um at worst
it can just be downright just bad
theology just like oh that's not good
you know kind of the worst of the
Christian tradition or something that
largely
maybe much of the church has actually
tried to move on from it but we're still
you know got these little things and so
we're going to be just kind of working
through a few of these like we'll just
take one a week and uh and go through
some of these so um that'll be kind of
the theories that we're in so with that
in mind the title and message this week
is God has a wonderful plan for your
life
and that's the saying you said I love
that idea well I mean I'm not saying I
hate it I like I'm it's this is one of
those I think that lacks um just lacks
some Nuance you know we need to we need
to Nuance fit a little bit like what
what do you mean plan you know like what
are you getting at
um so if this had a proof text in the
Bible where of course this isn't like an
exact quote from the Bible that's full
idea of the series
um but if there was like a proof text I
would say it would probably be um
Jeremiah chapter 29 verse 11 very famous
uh passage where it's interesting often
when we speak this passage we do it in
very individualistic terms of course was
spoken over an entire nation right it
wasn't like God was speaking this one
guy you know it's sort of to a people
but no matter
um here here it is so it says for I know
the plans I have for you declares the
Lord
now notice the plans
but good I mean it's good things right
plans to prosper you
and not to harm you
plans to give you hope
and a future
and to that I say yes in amen as we'll
get to I'm not like opposed I'm not
saying like this verse is wrong uh no I
think this is true I I think we just
what we do with it you know we sort of
run with this
and uh kind of end up taking it you know
unhelpful places and
um I think the way that plays out is you
know often when someone either quotes
this verse or
you know says Hey God has a God has a
wonderful plan for your life
where we run with that is to
um details we start to this is what I
call um the blueprint model of God's
will this is the the notion that God has
like very precise plans for each and
every aspect of your life
like I mean we're talking every step you
know did you just breathe that was the
plan you know I mean it's just how you
will you walk out this door or that door
it's all according to the plan you know
I mean just detail and I mean if it's
true for the little things
it's of course true for like all the big
things you know I mean from exactly
where you will live precisely who you
will marry where you will work I mean
it's all you know like it's all the plan
it's the plan and
um
this is kind of where we yeah we end up
running with this it's sort of like uh
well it's the blueprint like in the same
way an architect lays out the blueprints
for a building the way uh uh
cartographer you know a map that maker
kind of creates this map for exactly how
like every turn you need to get from
here Los Angeles to New York you know
like in the same way every plant is
every every curve is planned out so your
life right has been planned out in
detail this is often again maybe that's
some of you maybe that's not what you
hear when it's God has a wonderful plan
for your life
but for many of us
that's what we heard whatever was
intended or Jeremiah 29 11. I know the
plans I have for you you know and we're
like the plan okay there's the it's very
detailed blueprint idea and honestly I
mean I think at some level
truth be told this can be somewhat
anxiety relieving for folks
um you know like it is kind of helpful
to think like hey
at least
someone knows what's going on you know
um and well and especially when things
are going well
that's really where this is kind of a
cool model the blueprint you know
because it's this idea of like hey I am
like walking into my life every step I
am just in the will of God and it's
working and it's going great like the
spirit and I we are just on the same
page you know so it's awesome as long as
everything's going well the Trouble
Comes
when the stuff begins to hit the fan you
know
um when the cancer diagnosis rolls in
um
when the job is lost
uh when the the parent passes away
when the marriage that started so good
with such promise ends not in with so
much promise you know
um like it's suddenly this throws us
into
um you know utter chaos
and I've Just Seen over and over where
this theology just ends up crashing
upon the shoals of anxiety and doubt in
questions I think there's a few reasons
for this and I'll mention just two of
them first it's kind of the problem of
discernment
um you know like okay well let's say
there is there's like super super
detailed detail plan you know but and at
first that sounds so great but then you
start I mean maybe I don't know maybe
I'm just an anxious Soul um well not
maybe I'm an anxious Soul so maybe it's
just me and but I'm assuming there's a
then the problem becomes okay there is
the plan
how do I know it how do I know the plant
am I on track with the plan I'm not sure
you know what I mean like God I need you
to speak to me please show me the plan
you know and then there's like all these
other things which I don't know we
probably won't get into all these in the
series but you know there's one's like
well you know where God closes the door
he opens what a window you know and so
then I was just like well but
which window precisely and what does
that look like you know or how do I know
that door is really closed I mean did
not Jesus himself say those who knock
the door shall be open it's a
it's a test I need to keep on knocking
this is a persistence test and idea or
maybe not no no that's a closed door
Brett that's a close you need to look
for the window and but which one you
know can you see where it sort of
becomes like yeah the problem okay there
is the plan the blueprint is all there
but how do I know if I'm on track you
know
um but eventually you have to make a
decision so you launch out you make one
and you pray Lord I hope it's you know
did I just turn the tea leaves correctly
and you launch out and then this is the
second problem is um the problem of the
wrong decision
right so okay if God has this plan but
then like at a major juncture not like
to exit that door that door but you know
at a major life decision what if I make
the wrong decision
have I not
just
completely sent my life on a course of
utter disaster
like I mean that was it wasn't a small
thing it was like a big thing
you know
um I remember years ago I had
lunch with a friend that says I was on
staff at a previous church and another
kind of person there in the church there
took me out for lunch and we were just
talking at first it was like you know
normal small talk stuff how should we
good and then I could tell like oh he
kind of had you know someone of an
agenda here um not in a bad way but he
said uh man I gotta tell you like
so nervous
um
my wife and I we've been fighting so
much and I'm just I'm starting to worry
I'm starting to get questions man
and I was like questions you know what
do you what do you mean
he said well I'm just
I'm kind of worried
that may be she
like isn't the one
and I was like the one he's like you
know
the one
the one God chose for me you know
and uh he said and just imagine
if I married the wrong person
she married the wrong person
and that means whoever she was supposed
to marry
also married the wrong person
he said you could tell he's getting very
anxious and he's like imagine the ripple
effect you know and I said dude that's
the stupidest thing I've ever heard
I'm joking I did not say that I'm a good
pastor I'm a good person
um
I I honestly was this is probably a good
17 years ago now
um I can't remember exactly how I
responded I think what I just vaguely
recall it was something effect of like
well man
you're married now so I'm not sure how
much it matters you know like you're in
I think it's time to let it go and
actually I was thinking back like that
was a good 17 years ago now he's been
married for like over 20 years so I
guess I know she was the one I don't
know uh but you can can you see where
this becomes sort of the the worry the
fear the problem not only of discernment
but then after you've made the decision
of like the wrong decision and a lot of
that as this that story kind of hints
that comes from when the troubles hit
when the stuff hits the fan and it's
like it's problematic because there's
sort of two options here option A oh no
this is the plan this is the blueprint
right this divorce illness you know what
whatever the catastrophe is like no
that's the plan but in that case it sort
of brings up all sorts of questions of
like the goodness of God
which will actually get in more into
next week
um
the problem kind of evil and suffering
and such but or okay but or we say no no
that wasn't the plan he just messed it
up you know you made the wrong decision
but that of course comes with all of its
own sort of um problems and um needless
to say I just I think this whole
blueprint model
wrong model I think just my theological
opinion
um I think it's the kind of an unhelpful
paradigm
so
um you might wonder okay well then
what's the you know how should we think
about such things and
um
I think what we need is something more
dynamic
I'm going to call it the partnership
model the partnership model of God's
will this is where I creatively
um might even throw in the word actively
even though it's not the slide kind of
creatively actively
participate in the plans and the
purposes of God for the world in other
words it's not like my will and God's
will or like competing with one another
and he's like surprised at what I did
you know oh no you know like no no I
think
um in a lot of ways I think we need to
zoom out we need to see bigger and say
like God is up to something beautiful in
the world and he's not surprised or
caught off guard by what's going on but
neither is he willing evil and Terror
and horror like oh it's just part of the
blueprint you know like no
um the way the the Bible kind of frames
it well let me start here there's a a
word I did a message on this like a year
and a half ago so many of you weren't
here it was on the Greek word Telos
which I think is a helpful word this is
from the New Testament it means aim end
goal purpose
I think this is a helpful way to think
of God created all things with a Telos
including you an aim an end a goal a
purpose
because there's
where that God intends but there's room
for God's spirit to work there's room
for you to like do things make decisions
right to actively participate in the
plans and purposes of God and and God's
in the midst of that it keeps working it
weaving it towards the good now
to even take all the way back to Genesis
right you can recall that moment where
God's creating and God says oh it's it's
good it's good it's very good right so
the world's created with this beautiful
Telos but of course
um capital S sin capital e evil death
has stolen into the world
things have gotten sideways things have
gone wrong
right things that are happening that are
not according to the plan so to speak
not that God's caught off guard but it's
not like God Wills evil into the world
or God's The Source again we'll get more
into the details on this next week
um so clearly things have gone sideways
however God has not given up
On The World God as we know from
scripture sins the prophets
God sins Whispers of the Holy Spirit
into every corner of the cosmos and
finally God has sent his very son Jesus
Christ he lived he died he rose again he
ascended to do what to bring us and all
creation back into alignment with God's
tell us back into alignment with God's
heart and purposes and way
and so I think this becomes very
instructive for how we're to live where
it's less about like wait do I take a
left step and then what's your good will
Lord you know we worry less about every
little decision and we start worrying
more about kind of our um our inward
disposition like Lord
bring me in my heart into alignment with
you
God help me to love
help me to love help me to see with your
eyes help me to will the good that you
are Lord in every single moment of my
life if
you can't go wrong
you can't go wrong I'm not even worried
about like but where do I live I don't
do whatever you want I mean
in essence but do it from that heart
right so not that you couldn't maybe
make a bad decision about where you live
so to speak but it would be bad not
because like oh no the blueprint uh you
know it would be well I chose that place
because of my own deep insecurities and
I bought way more Health than it
probably could afford because I wanted
to impress my parents you know I mean
like you could see where that's maybe
like oh okay maybe we're kind of out of
alignment here but it's not not because
of some controlling plan that God does
that make sense where um in other words
that we might say that God's plan for
all of us um in many ways it's
Christ was and what the Holy Spirit was
leading them to do as they did their
creative best with it
it's his will that those who
come to the table
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
we're gonna close with the song that we
learned a couple weeks ago it's called
you hold it all and as we reflect on
what Brett shared tonight and kind of
hold that in our thoughts and what what
does it mean to live in the plan and the
will of God
I hope that this song connects kind of
in a new way in a light where we are
just trusting God with our life and
you guys are welcome to stand with us
and sing along or if you feel like you'd
rather sit and soak it in that's fine
too
God we bring you the work of our hands
and now lay it down lay it at your feet
what we've done what we've built what
we've broken
lay it down lay it at your feet
you hold it all Jesus you hold it it all
worried Hearts wear red hands we can
bodies lay it down lay it at your feet
where we've used what we've lost well
we've wasted lay it down lay it at your
feet
[Music]
it all Jesus you hold it all
you hold it all Jesus
[Music]
lay it down lay it at your feet
and even if nothing comes to fruition
I lay it down lay it out of your fears
wow thank you worship team and thank you
all so much for joining us this evening
if you're new here we'd love for you to
leave your information there's a tiny
little table outside in the hallway and
there's some cards there just simple
information so that we can contact you
and let you know that we appreciate you
being here my name is Janine Horton and
if you need any kind of support any kind
of prayer a hug need someone to listen
I'll be here so you can find me after
the service
here at the table
we're committed to giving and so I
wanted to tell you why my wife Leslie
and I give and we give here because we
believe in the mission of this church
and that is to shift a generation from
reactionary to Visionary through the
life and work of Christ through Jesus
and we believe in that so strongly that
we're weekly online givers and so what I
would like to for you to think about is
it says a generation a generation is you
it's you okay it's everybody from the
nursery to the eldest person that we
have here and so I'd like to invite you
to become a regular Giver
you can join us in this supporting us
financially by dropping your donation
into the tiny little box on the table
or you can scan the QR code that's on
the screen or you can go to the website
at thetabletx.org
[Music]
all right it's time for a benediction if
you all would like to stand or you may
remain sitting get into a posture of
receiving I'll pray this blessing over
you
thank you
you are a child of God
you you are a child of God this is true
on your best day
and it's true on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go filled with the assurance that you
are loved you are worthy and you are
accepted Just As You Are
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same Gifts of
Grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with be blessed have
a good week and we hope to see you at
hat Creek Burger Company in sexy right
after the service
thank you
all our dreams other plans our Ambitions
lay you down lay it at your feet and
even if nothing comes to fruition
lay it down lay it at your feet cause
you hold it all Jesus you holding
[Music]
you
hold it
all Jesus
[Music]
it's even if nothing comes to fruition
lay it down lay it at your feet
and lay you down lay it on your feet
[Music]